at Slamdance is there a difference
between the short film submissions and
feature film submissions in regards to
the judging process and how you go about
selecting films that make it into the
festival is there a difference there's a
little bit of a difference in this
between shorts and features when their
program assignments in the sense that
we're shorts it's a the definition of
what's a first time director for example
is it's much more definitive if you're
talking my features like okay asses
person died feature before that showed
up on IMDb or whatever we're shorts that
distinction is much you know more
amorphous because everyone does a lot of
shorts and you know from when they're 10
years old you know until whatever so
it's a so I you know it's it's less
about is it your first time film and
it's more strictly about the quality of
the film and and and that sort of thing
but otherwise the process is pretty much
the same we have committees we more or
less have three committees one for
shorts one for a narrative features and
one for documentary features although
that one way that committee may also
look at documentary shorts and it's a
little different every year how we
organize it and they're all made up of
filmmakers alumni filmmakers and you
know sometimes you get feature
filmmakers jurying eeram you know
selecting on the shorts committee
sometimes you get short filmmakers
selecting on the features committee kind
of depends how much time each individual
person has because but we have about 40
or 50 people that look at films every
year and then eat away each film get
seen by at least two people it's about
the same
you